have we tried starving it of oxygen
there he didn't ask sounding bored with
a conversation already yes we have
Dr Kelly grumbled in reply we're able to
create a vacuum remove 99 of the air
from its containment chamber and its
life science drop
I'm sensing there's a butt coming next
the research assistant side rolling his
eyes typical but 682 was able to fill
the chamber with a gas mixture of ozone
chlorine Xenon and uh I forget the
foundation doctor answered getting more
and more agitated point is it was able
to form and expel chemicals even without
any active life signs ah it's almost
like there's a reason we call it the
hottest throw a reptile I just wish I
could figure out what it was for hidden
retorted making no attempt to mask his
sarcasm giving a dry chuckle much to Dr
Kelly's annoyance it was a debate that
had been going on for what felt like the
entire history of the SCP Foundation how
could anyone possibly kill as CP 682 the
creature had long been one of the most
infamous anomalies that the foundation
had ever encountered so much so that the
to destroy reptile was synonymous with
the organization but the Mandate still
stood that it needed to be destroyed as
soon as someone was able to figure out a
way although they hadn't quite exhausted
every possible option just yet most of
the researchers were running short on
ideas thinking up a plan to kill 682 was
made all the harder knowing the creature
had survived and regenerated from every
single previous test if there were
something some neutralization method
that was going to work surely they would
have found it by now uh maybe we should
just leave it researcher assistant for
Heathen suggested I mean we've got it
sitting in a tank of acid perpetually
melting it as fast as it can
reconstitute its body while it's like
that 682 is hardly a threat to anyone
hardly a threat Dr Kelly scuffed clearly
more than perturbed her dead wrong were
hidden as long as that monstrosity
continues to live it poses a constant
threat to every single human being on
this planet help every life form in the
world it hates everything else that much
look I'm just saying that after recent
faster we're discussing this in shoe and
maybe the whole his voice drilled off
for a moment after the situation that
led to maybe it's better if we leave 682
alone
it seems that every time we tried to
come up with a solution to our reptile
problem something always goes wrong the
whole thing's car stock like a big joke
where the punchline is more and more of
us end up dead while 682 keeps on living
just despite us you have no idea what
you're talking about Kelly yelled
infuriated by such a suggestion that
trying to destroy 682 once and for all
was little more than exercise and
futility hey hey take it easy
subordinate reply trying to calm Kelly
down you gotta admit doc it seems more
impossible than well all the other
impossible things that we see in this
job it's an important mission of the SCP
Foundation for Eden Dr Brown holding
back his rage to safeguard Humanity from
anomalous threats I'm convinced we just
need to find the right set of variables
the right conditions or equipment and I
we can kill this thing once and for all
but where do we go from here I mean
we've tried Conventional Weapons other
anomalies if other powerful scps can
kill this thing what chance do we have
maybe it's a case of finding the right
one Dr Kelly theorized
scp-738 and scp-743 both failed we
couldn't even fit 682 in the booths of
the Clockworks if we wanted to so back
to the drawing board what haven't we
tried
why don't we just throw scp-035 on it
for hidden remarked clearly making
another snide sarcastic joke that thing
wouldn't even fit over 682's big lizard
snout and would probably just slide off
onto the floor hold on Kelly replied
pondering the idea for a moment since
being assigned to the site containing
scp-682 studying the reptile up close he
had become determined to figure out some
way to finally kill it it would make him
a legend in the history of the
foundation being the one who did what
they had failed to do for so many years
that might just work doc I was kidding
that doc his research assistant replied
turning to see that Dr Kelly was already
racing down the corridors of the
facility that is an absurd suggestion Dr
bright answered when Kelly came rushing
up to him hastily explaining his plan
for scp-682's termination no listen here
Jack please just hear me out Kelly urged
yes scp-035 is a dangerous anomaly in
its own right but it's also deadly to
the wearer it secretes that substance
that corros the body of whoever or
whatever wears it right and you came up
with the idea to play such an object
over the head of a creature that can
regenerate and adapt to almost any form
of damage bright retorted before the
other Foundation doctor could finish
that's precisely my proposal
look we already keep scp-682 contained
in a vatic acid for safety right Melt
Away its body before it has a chance to
fully regenerate keeping it in this
Perpetual state of healing and
sustaining damage at the same speed now
what if we go the whole Hawk let scp-035
take control the reptile into the mask
drenches it in Black goo melting it down
for good and you've considered the other
possibilities right Bright Eyes trying
his best to walk away from Kelly as they
spoke that scp-035 takes full control of
682 and is granted an immortal host that
might not degrade under its secretion
there's a far higher likelihood that
scp-035 wouldn't even fit on the reptile
it faces the wrong shape the possessive
mask is made for humanoid faces not
reptilian ones yeah but the reptile is
able to adapt is it not Kelly fired back
correct and if we allow it to adapt to
scp-035 we could even have a greater
monstrosity on our hands a hybrid of the
possessive mask and the hard to destroy
reptile oh my God Jack Bright shouted
fed up with having to listen to Kelly's
outlandish idea a being like that would
be hell-bent on destruction I'm sorry Dr
Kelly the answer is no
no just send it up the chain on my
behalf I just need clearance to run one
test
I can take it higher but I'm telling you
now the answer won't change Dr Brent
admitted agreeing just to get Kelly to
back off sure enough later that very
same day Dr Kelly received a notice from
the senior research staff his superiors
within the foundation Dr Kelly we have
learned of your proposed experiment for
terminating scp-682 unfortunately after
confirming we have decided this course
of action would pose too greater risks
to the safety of civilians as well as
our own staff here at the SCP Foundation
additionally Dr bright has raised
concerns with us about your recent
obsessive Behavior we would kindly ask
you to attend a mandatory psychiatric
evaluation tomorrow at 1500 hours to
assess and potentially reassign you
given your interest in using scp-035 we
feel in your current state you may be at
risk of being influenced by the psionic
effects of the possessive mask the
message from the research supervisors
was still open on Kelly's computer
terminal when verheedan went to check on
him it looked like the doctor had
started typing a response you idiot want
to psych eval me you want to ignore the
actual present threat to the foundation
the longer we keep that reptile alive
the more everyone and everything is at
risk but you want to persecute me for
trying to come up with a radical
solution if you're all too cowardly
tagged and I have no choice but to Kelly
had left the rest unfinished without
hitting send although it didn't take
much of a reach for his research
assistant to realize that his sentence
would have ended with do it myself his
heart pounding regretted ever suggesting
using the possessive mask as a joke for
heating caught up in Ran racing through
the corridors as fast as he could
towards the containment cell for scp-035
he had a sick feeling in his stomach
that he might find Dr Kelly already
there acting out of a fit of
uncontrollable anger and what he thought
was a moral obligation to destroy
scp-682 Dr Kelly had stolen some
amnestics from the foundation storerooms
placing two cups of coffee with the
memory altering drugs he'd offered the
hot beverage to the pair of armed guards
stay outside the room where scp-035 was
held accepting what they thought to be
an act of kindness from a foundation
doctor both security officers had
quickly forgotten why they were standing
around so idly luckily the friendly
Foundation doctor had reminded them they
had reached the end of their shift and
were free to go and punch the clock with
no reason to question him the guards
wandered away leaving Dr Kelly alone
with scp-035 then The Whispers started
they seemed garbled unintelligible at
first but the closer that Dr Kelly grew
to the glass case the clearer the voice
of the possessive mask started to sound
so
it hissed I hear you have a reptile
problem doctor
the loud wailing of alarms told verhiden
he was already too late
scp-035 had breached containment thanks
to a rogue Dr Kelly no doubt the
research assistant cursed his own big
mouth for even mentioning scp-035 as an
option for destroying the reptile
although he could have never known Kelly
would take it so seriously as a
suggestion but now the doctor's
obsession with being responsible for
finally ending scp-682 was running
rampant turning a corner of the research
assistant stopped in this tracks he had
quickly realized it was pointless
heading towards the scp-035 containment
chamber Dr Kelly would already have what
he needed from there but there was only
one place he'd be heading once he had
the possessive mask in tow taking the
corresponding Corridor verhiden raced
through the foundation facility toward
the direction of the room housing the
vat of acid where the heart to destroy
reptile was waiting a trail of bodies
scalded and scorched with a viscous
black substance told him he was on the
right track it was the same corrosive
secretion that leaked from the
possessive mask meaning that either
Kelly had forced someone to wear it or
Worse had been manipulated into putting
it on himself if scp-035 had convinced
him it might have the answer to killing
the reptile then little could have
stopped Dr Kelly from bringing it to
scp-682 whom the mass could use as its
next host and to researcher verhidden's
horror it looked like exactly that was
about to happen as he arrived at
scp-682's containment cell Talk stop he
yelled in desperation this has gone too
far please Dr Kelly turned to look over
at his assistant his face now obscured
by the carved exaggerated porcelain grin
of the possessive mask its smile was one
of Twisted Glee like it was taunting for
hidden for even trying to stop it the
corrosive liquid was leaking out from
underneath it spilling down Dr Kelly's
bare neck and onto his shoulders rapidly
melting away everything it touched
meanwhile the acid from scp-682's tank
was starting to be be drained away and
the monster was beginning to stir
hooking two fingers under the edge of
the porcelain comedy mask Kelly started
to Wrench It off his face compelled by
scp-035 The Mask knew of the foundation
doctor's plan and was far less
interested in helping kill 682 as it was
using the reptile as an immortal host
finally one that wouldn't degrade in the
same way so many others had before with
the last of his strength he pulled the
mask away his brain dead body succumbing
to its injuries and dropping the mask
right into
scp-682's tank as scp-035 landed on the
creature's head it let out a wild pain
War black streaks of corrosive secretion
began to Trail down the reptile making
it thrash at the pain of the substance
burning and dissolving the outer layers
of its thick hide the noise is let out
by 682 were enough to pull verhidan's
eyes away from Dr Kelly whose body had
collapsed lifelessly he had died trying
to bring an end to a monster the
foundation had never successfully
destroyed yet another life lost in the
pursuit of killing the unkillable
reptile as the life-hating lizard
thrashed about looking like it was about
to burst free of its cage and rage the
research assistant shot across the room
to reverse the acid draining from the
tank the foundation security team
arrived in the containment room just as
the acid tank had very nearly been fully
refilled although he had no idea if it
would have an effect where heedan had
stopped it just short of also submerging
the possessive mask in the acid too
which still seemed to be precariously
balanced on the 682's head not covering
its face as a cleaning crew arrived to
remove kellyanne the bodies he'd left in
his wake the foundation had to come up
with a plan for removing scp-035 without
their staff falling into the acid vat no
no no hold on for hidden insisted I know
this started as a joke between the doc
and me and I had no idea he had taken it
so seriously but look he pointed to the
inside of the tank the gigantic
reptilian monster was completely still l
or the possessive mask still at streaks
of its corrosive substance drip over its
head and it looked to be taking effect
still dissolving every part of the
reptile it came into contact with maybe
it could work the research assistant
mused Retreat to a safe Zone the
security Chief instructed we are to
await orders on further course of action
if you want to observe you'll have to do
it from a distance falling back it
seemed the entire Foundation was waiting
with baited breath to see what would
happen next through back and forth radio
chatter with their superiors neither
verheeden nor the security forces seem
to know how to proceed from the outside
the book like scp-682 and scp-035 were
at a stalemate but in the back of their
minds everyone had to wonder how long
was this going to last what nobody
noticed however was the unique way in
which scp-682 had adapted to coming into
contact with scp-035 a lump had formed
on the topmost part of the reptile's
head its scales had parted allow
allowing for the fleshy growth to swell
until it was roughly the size and shape
of the average human face it lacked any
of the usual characteristics no eyes
nose or mouth but seemed to work as a
way to better Mount the possessive mask
since it couldn't fit over the hard to
destroy reptile's long lizard-like
features additionally what looked like
the black corrosive substance from
scp-035 leaking onto 682 and melting
away at the mask's new host actually
seemed to be another adjustment the
creature had made to its own physiology
instead of dissolving the reptile the
substance was being absorbed diverted to
a specially formed gland inside the
monster that was now safely storing the
corrosive goo within its own mouth but
further within beneath all the external
and even internal changes occurring to
scp-682's body a far greater change was
taking place deep in the recesses of the
Twisted murderous mind of scp-682 was an
intruder a presence that the reptile
could feel trying to bore its way in to
not only make itself known but to take
over the pair of them the
consciousnesses of both these anomalies
were battling each other for Supremacy
the hard to destroy reptile wanting to
retain control of its own body and mind
and the possessive Mass Desiring total
dominion over its Newfound host
scp-682 have long been known to have a
high level of psionic resistance halting
the spread of scp-035's telepathic
influence however because the reptile's
body had adapted and acclimatized to the
mask's corrosive secretion it meant 035
was able to persist hanging on and still
trying to force its way into the
reptile's mind you hate them all so much
the voice of scp-035 echoed from inside
the hard to destroy reptile's head don't
bother it's not back in reply you are
alive that makes you as disgusting and
putrid to me as the rest of them but
think what we could achieve
together the mask whispered for a moment
the reptile considered an alliance both
it and The Mask possessed a shared
hatred towards Humanity although 682s
extended to all other forms of life
including the sentient comedy mask at
now War though even a temporary
cooperation between the two might have
its benefits
scp-682 had no intention of remaining
bound with the possessive mask for
longer than it needed and in much the
same vein
scp-035 was only proposing such a
partnership to avoid being removed from
perhaps one of the few beings that could
wear it for an extended period of time
without being dissolved entirely outside
in the containment chamber the
foundation Personnel had been instructed
to remove scp-035 from the reptile
despite concerns that the sun removal of
the Mask would cause the monster to
enter a rage State the possessive mask
was now fused with the flash of scp-682
through its specialized protrusion and
the foundation sphere was that the
longer the pair of anomalies stayed
bonded the more the hard to destroy
reptile would be able to adapt against
other powerful scps so research
assistant for Hedon had been ordered to
increase the acid content of the tank to
full capacity hopefully burning the
tissue connecting the reptile and The
Mask to each other before the white
porcelain of scp-035 could slip under
the rising acid a clot arm reached up
over the boiling vat and pulled the
research assistant under screaming he
landed in the tank with a splash
followed by a rapid hiss clambering up
out of its containment tank the hybrid
of scp-682 and scp-035 roared as the
combined creature freed itself from
containment in the chamber below all
Helm broke loose security officers reach
for their weapons not even waiting for
the order before they opened fire
bullets pinged off the porcelain comedy
mask that was embedded in the top of the
reptile's head barely scratching the
surface and unable to pierce the
monster's scales some guards charged in
only for the reptile to spew a molten
black substance from the specialized
glands in
it was channeling the corrosive
secretions from scp-035 into a weapon
the resulting ooze dissolving the
security team as they approached
stopping their futile attempt to
recontain it before they could even try
witnessing this knowing their own
imminent deaths were near researchers
and remaining Foundation security turned
heal and ran for their lives as
Containment Breach alarms blared through
the facility although both anomalies
were secretly intending to betray one
another for now
scp-682 and scp-035 were free to unleash
their combined monstrous form on the
humans they both hated the most their
captors the SCP Foundation now go check
out what if scp-343 wore scp-035 and the
whole story what if scp-096 wore scp-035
for more horrors of other anomalies
wearing the possessive mask